Kelly chew ballet is an organic
chemistry professor at the University of
Capetown and he explains the health
implications if a patient is infected
with both corona virus and malaria
firstly it's the impact of Kovach 19 on
not just the malaria as a disease in
terms of the clinical symptoms or the
pathology in etc etc but it's also about
the impact on the performance of malaria
medicines and in terms of their
effectiveness but it's also the other
way around is the impact of malaria on
Kobe 19 and/or the impact of malaria
medications and Kobe 19 so often when
you have comorbidity one disease can
enhance the other disease because of the
downturn in the economy and and of
course people losing jobs of course then
malaria medications can become very
expensive and at most of the the poorer
communities can really not afford them
enough it's also the impact OB 90 apart
from the fact that people who are not
easily able to access malaria
medications it's also that then they
could resort to other measures for
example self medication self medication
or relying on untested remedies for
malaria which could have you know
serious negative consequences on the
disease including the development of
resistance